bella a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovi video io sono parigi oggi
siamo su non sapeva fare questa cosa in
realtà però volevo fare un po di scena
siamo su wire lips che questo gioco
horror figo
ogni settimana ho trovato una foto del
mio amico mancato morente in qualche
parte di qualche parte della casa mia
mamma lavora oggi ed è apparso ancora
una volta
[Musica]
ma chi era era il protagonista ero io
ero io questa foto ancora la bruci tu
hai dirmi che continua a comparire in
casa sta foto e tu continui a bruciarla
ma brucia la casa a posto a cosa stai lì
a fare vela salvezza madonna che bel
quasi schacter design shark il design
aisha to de quito ha un po e gilda
fucking perfetto lei era però è
tutt'altro che un horror è tutto fuorché
pauroso c'è guardarsi anche in from vai
a vedere da dove arriva a roma
io non ho sentito nessun rumore in tutto
questo sotto can do the year e da un'ora
e mezza mano è cascato un libro che è
paura nel nostro libro the book back
quindi basta fare avanti dietro con la
teiera basta era dugas mtc lo scotch e
brooke vecchi come chiama lo guardo
mentre vado via non lo guardo è a
l'ouest quindi devo farmi un bagno e poi
riposarmi
va bene workshop alla voce sola faccia
anche io che pensavo lasciare tutta ci
sarà qualcosa nello specchio tra 32 no
scherzavo
sto facendo cose normalissime e come se
dovesse succedere questo è un momento
all'altro che non sta succedendo
quindi un gioco un po strano resti in
guidato museums norest ma dai veramente
vuoi mettere la musica per addormentarti
sei pazza voi mettete la musica per
addormentare i ragazzi siete bestie di
satana dove fai dormire se c'è un se c'è
la musica dormire in mai mai
dunque è un gioco vera è uno dei giochi
più strani nella partenza che abbia mai
visto
ma si aprono i porno maya sto presenza a
sono i crediti gioco a ok niente ei
buongiorno anche mi sveglio così war
child nightmare che è terribile incubo
dall'edizione o mal di testa
mica sei veramente da buttare ti sveglia
e mal di testa stai morendo non riesce a
fare un tè prendi le pillole nel bagno
ok c'è un amo che non c'era prima che
tanto prende le robe scompaiono sono
tipo collezionabili cos'è vado a
pigliare pillole tu che veramente figo
il fatto che personaggio si muova così
stranamente fa impazzire sta roba mi
piace mal di testa e cioè veramente il
sintomo del mal di testa
siccome c'è si vede che mal di testa lo
vedi dal da come si muove lo schermo ok
le pillole effetto moment act e passa
tutto ciao casa orco demonio
se sconnessa la corrente a in it goes to
bed vado
ok cioè misuri trento a devo prendere il
libro che continua a cascata per terra
ovviamente facebook gameloft o di
dillinger o di di ii e iii red passion
dio buono
cosa c è di tutele flashlight bassman
gazzolo world tela flashlight la teniamo
giustamente in cucina vicino ai piatti è
ovvio perché dove la vuoi tenere una
flashlight ecco delle policy fendi di
fenice pence chiamerò i vicini se
succede qualcosa adesso la maniglia
posso go to the room enit message my
friend is less un esplosivo è come li
messaggio con la computer non c'era il
telefono al telefono senza aiuto c'è
satana in casa sembra pure il computer
cince pato ci manca solo quello ma mai
che intraprende message feb
oddio sta succedendo al collega
iniziano a succedere come sempre più
strane o qualcuna apparecchiato per sei
i canapi cioè ci sono impronte sul muro
che portano di qua io vado di qua
forester forester dove in bagno
christian ha visto anche lei no rega
orribile orribile massacro santo iddio
ma non c'e nessuno ma chi cazzo
e scompari sciuto e niente è andato bene
l'ovale mi piacerà satana nello specchio
capisco e quindi basta che il malaga
lancia le cose e orlando
facciamo come che che bacchettava
dall'armadio mano ce ne sono ben e che
peccato da pavia si è tornato ma io ero
tutto ero tutto preso male porco demonio
visto veramente la cosa più brutta della
mia vita
avrò gli incubi per sempre
cosa devo fare qui burqa [ __ ] vacca
non c'e neanche l'obiettivo non so che
posso fare io cioè che message is on the
left of certe proprio quello che vorrei
fare in questo momento guardare il
computer i messaggi al computer
c'è veramente il demonio in casa
guardiamo i messaggi al computer idirect
ai 4 metri vestito ciao i can't click
cacciatori
clicca su fai a rue part of me contro te
che sono la scritta anyway urca [ __ ]
porca devo finire giocasta roba devo
guardare altro devo giochiamo hello
kitty sui motori dreams con le robe lì
porca [ __ ] che brutta roba da me
n'ero neanche accorto che sto guardando
alla tromba ok
stavo leggendo l'obiettivo magari mi
guardo meglio lo schermo alla seconda
chiama mamma chiama mamma mamma mamma
c'è c'è tutto il girone infernale in
casa a chi cazzo è chiamato il grande
fratello è dovuto godere
infatti non ci andiamo a no sia aperto
no non si è aperto non ci andiamo noi ci
andiamo
c'è niente di positivo la neve in cucina
che invece in cucina e tutto allegro e
funziona tutto questo rumore porco
demonio chiesto d'umore chiesto rumore
perché voglio senza offesa è perché so
che sei qua non ti vedo
so che madonna che brutta roba visto
allo specchio rimaniamo in questa parte
della casa controllare robe tipo vasca
da bagno pillole non è che sono state
non è che è tutto un incubo
alla fine poi si sveglia che era lei col
mal di testa prima di andare a dormire
vuoto tra polaroid panabaker a cero
controllare gli angoli degli specchi che
anzi mi cigola la lampadina sempre
quelle cose brutte che succedono ogni
tanto is it endless e senza fine e
speriamo di no sennò stiamo quasi tutto
il giorno a meno che non debba girarmi
andare all'indietro ma non penso che è
successo
sento cose
c'è una porta cucina occhio dietro occhi
dietro c'è qualcosa
no forse ho sbagliato io non ti voltare
entra chiudi entra chiudi ente chiudi
entra chiudi entra chiudi entra e chiudi
entra e chiudi e chiudi guai stesso non
lo so però chiudi brava
adesso si apre per così se si è sempre
corridoi o no adesso si è messo a posto
il corridoio che cos'è questo che ne so
il braccialetto di hina all we need is
on bari turina para para medici se ne
desse ma è morta mortali na let's golf
c'è un impiccato nel coso non è un
impiccato e un'ombra è un'ombra di
qualcuno impiccato che starò a chi la
tira
c'era ma non c'era niente appeso o
cacchio però io e la mia ombra lì basta
via la torcia più la torcia mi serve via
la pira via via subito
corri corri corri previa talk show bravo
bravo punta punta che non vedo niente
santo di dio da gasol i miei questo era
were l'ex episodi 1 continueremo nel
prossimo molto molto figo è diventato
molto scheri alla fine però io non rubo
sarà perché noi fatto di jumps che era è
fatto di atmosfera molto bello giuro
all'inizio era un po lento ma pian piano
fighissimo sia piaciuto previste per sé
lo coltivi nel se volete che lo
continuità prossima bisogno iscrivete
anche ai sassi iscriviti molto
importante la campanellina quella
bellissima cosa a forma di campana dato
di schiacciare se non vedete i prossimi
video che escono a che non li volete
perdere che fai te nei primi inoltre
privi e noi ci diamo come sempre al
prossimo video e la ragazza
[Musica]